hey guys it's justine and today we're
going to be chatting a little bit about
the apple arcade update that is
happening today or depending upon when
you're watching this
it has already happened and it's out i
have been a huge fan of the apple arcade
subscription service from apple it's
basically a way to get a bunch of games
every single month and also updates to
some of their previous existing games
but this latest update is very very
exciting you guys might remember i think
it was about a year and a half ago when
the apple art
actually launched my sister and i went
to
cupertino for one of their events and we
got a chance to play games
and hang out with other people and
obviously being a huge apple fan and
also a huge fan of video games being
able to go to apple
to cupertino to the steve jobs theater
and play games was like the coolest
thing ever and at the time i was
thinking wow this is like a once in a
lifetime experience
and now over a year later of really not
leaving the house
it kind of makes me realize how
incredible that experience was and how
actually it
might have been a once-in-a-lifetime
experience but i do hope one day we can
return to in-person events today is a
big day
for the apple arcade because they're
launching not only a bunch of new games
but they're also
re-releasing some apple store classics
so a bunch of games that you may have
purchased like monument valley
mini metro threes root ninja classic
a million run and a few others and
what's really cool is they're calling
these the app store grades so all of
these games that are
highlights or have been previous hits in
the app store you'll be able to get
those
i was gonna say for free but you're
actually paying a subscription but
what's cool is in monument valley for
example
to get all of the levels all of them
will be unlocked and all of this
is unlocked with your apple arcade
subscription the other thing that i
think is really exciting
especially for a lot of people who
played these types of games is the
timeless classics
like chess backgammon crossword puzzles
and even solitaire i mean come on like
these are actually they're timeless
classics like they
did aim this appropriately and then what
makes apple arcade really fun is of
course they do have some of the apple
arcade originals and there is one
original that i am
so excited about freaking organ trail
i grew up playing this game so the fact
that it's now being re-released on the
iphone as an apple arcade classic game i
can play it on my phone i can play it on
my apple tv i can play it on my ipad
is really freaking cool a few other
games that are launching in this update
are simon's cat story time star trek
legends
cut the rope remastered which i'm very
excited about this game because i
absolutely loved this game before and
now it's all remastered
in 3d and it looks beautiful i remember
being so obsessed with this game
i cannot wait to play it again and
become just as obsessed
all over again their song pop party clap
hands golf
fantasian wonder box the adventure maker
and world of demons just to name a few
apple arcade is available for 4.99 a
month as a subscription but you can also
get it bundled in with the apple one
subscription
currently in the apple arcade there's
about over i think 180 games which is
pretty substantial if you think about
what you're getting for 4.99 a month i
have a couple of the games on my phone
really the one that i really really
really want to play is the oregon trail
oh my gosh this is so crazy playing this
here we are march 6 1849
we are lost aren't we yeah we are oh no
our wagon
has fallen david has a broken leg
oh david you're such a hot mess you're
always causing trouble
you think i'd remember how to play this
game but i actually i don't okay let's
see do we want to treat julia's favor or
do we want to heal david's broken leg
treat my fever we don't need david i'm
julia in this
and i'm being selfish fix that up fix
that up all right our wagon is healed
our money is going down significantly
paris is joining our part oh my god we
have a friend
this is incredible oh david's broken leg
i should have probably healed his leg
alfred is exhausted well take a freaking
nap alfred
hey alfred have a coffee sip wake up
alfred is no longer exhausted i wish it
was that simple
hunting ground oh i'll freaking do some
hunting
oh you hate getting up early where oh no
it's raining should i slow my roll you
guys got this come on we gotta pull
through
should i feed everybody do or do they
eat themselves not like eat themselves
but like
do they just get hungry and eat this
rainbow is definitely uplifting
i think they they feed themselves oh my
gosh we healed his leg
he's not well oh my god look at you guys
lazy lazy you guys are lazy bums
ammunition oh where the heck am i gonna
get ammunition at yep
i think that's probably enough right
look how close i am these are like some
close range shots
oh god i'm terrible i'm pathetic i'm
pathetic look at this
can i carry that all back that was the
question i guess so oh
a hair is um how do i heal you i don't
have any medicine i don't have anything
how do we get ourselves clean gosh our
oxen is tired
you need a doctor oh god he's not he's
gonna die
yeah i hope you will too we're only 10
miles to go
suck it up david walked here on a broken
leg
you're fine god look how disgusting we
are
we don't really have any money oh my god
he's throwing up
oh he is not well he needs to go he's
not well
okay harris have a good time we have
made it to independence the very
beginning oh we got a guidebook
do you want to jump straight into the
main game oh my goodness so that was
basically just the tutorial
we have so much more to do well look at
that give me some money
appreciate it okay let's play cut the
rope because
this being one of my favorites let's
freaking do it
omnom deliver candy there we go i mean
the game is so
simple that it does get a little complex
as you go if you've played this game
before
okay i did terrible i did a very poor
job we're gonna do that again
oh shoot i cut all of my ropes
i missed it no
yes it's like the game is so simple yeah
this way yeah oh no oh no i've messed up
[Music]
there we go nice look at all these
levels we're gonna be
so busy this weekend okay let's play
another one let's play
song pop party this one looks really fun
hi i'm amanda welcome to song pop party
we're gonna do is just a solo because
ryden solo
i'm riding below yeah you can collect my
data i don't care i'll just click
essentials
so it's gonna give me a copyright
probably yeah i know this
so they play a song and then i'd say who
it is i did choose the easy one
i've never played this game before it
was actually really fun i don't know
oh the cpu missed it i can't play any of
these songs because they're all copy
written
but i'm doing really well and i'm proud
of myself i just guessed because i knew
it wasn't any of the others yay can you
guys believe that i came in first i beat
the computer
so dalla did okay let's play simon's cat
little case in the pants he gets on the
fancy seat he's eating the food he's
eating the food
your significant other does not enjoy
your pet then it's time to go
hey get that quick snack so it's time to
do some gardening
this cat wants out he wants his freedom
so do i gotta build a wall okay i have a
new task i've gotta fix the garden gate
so a lot of games that i play normally
are basically
pay to play and pay to win so i end up
spending so much money so games like
this especially through apple arcade
i don't have to like basically pay to
win it's just a game
based off of playing the game oh okay
what do we do oh my god we're collecting
oh oh gosh these types of games oh we're
all in trouble now
whatever happened to justine oh apple
arcade released some new games
she's never seen again i love tile
matching games
it's funny because this is one of the
games that i was like uh i don't know if
this is one that i'm going to be into
alright fix that gate dude
oh my god we have a new neighbor oh get
it i want to play more matching
i want to keep matching things look at
him cleaning
oh look at our beautiful clean yard
oh that neighbor is going to be like can
i come over for a barbecue
oh she also has a cat oh
boy i see where this is going i don't
want to do any more spoilers for this
game for you guys but
nba 2k21 let's let's do it
not gonna lie i don't really remember
the last time i played a basketball game
i also don't know anything about
basketball
should the lakers play the lakers that's
confusing play the kings
i just thought you know we would keep it
like a california like a local like a
local gathering
all right here's our our starting lineup
do your stuff let's get out there we
gotta this looks
really good i wish i could put my face
on
somebody in the crowd okay here's our
controls
um boom is that me
what is my team who am i even this is
gonna be an
absolute tragedy i'm just gonna okay
do i who am i even oh i have to go
somewhere
i gotta do something okay here's the
thing
just get get over there and just shoot
be talented
i don't even know how to play basketball
so like this is really
quite problematic i know you you don't
i know you wanna um hey you did
something wrong
yeah i don't know what you did how am i
supposed to know
because i don't understand the sport can
i hit people
i mean a new girl looks like i'll
suppose
[Applause]
okay you take the ball and then i'm just
gonna pass it
and hope that like you can get that ball
in oh really i just want to hit someone
guys we're losing okay dude let's take
this ball
pass it to our friend pass it again
and then we're gonna shoot
i'm getting the sport down i got this
here's the thing i actually played
basketball in middle school
was i any good no you know how short i
am
i'm 5'3 do you know how short i was
probably in middle school
get that oh my god
oh i got the ball back it's almost like
i'm starting to understand the controls
that was a really long pass you idiot
why would you ever do that that's
something that i even know is a bad idea
oh oh okay wait a minute no no we're
going to keep going
oh get that ball get that ball get that
ball okay now we're gonna stop before i
get any worse uh this is actually pretty
fun
considering i haven't played a
basketball game ever and i don't even
understand the sport
well thank you guys so much for watching
those were just a couple of games that i
really wanted to test out here on apple
arcade i've been such a huge fan of
apple arcade since it launched really
cool to kind of get a chance to play
some of these games they're now
available on the app store and i got to
play them here for you guys today in
this video
i'd love to hear from you guys do you
have upload arcade and if you've been
using it for the past year
what games have you guys been playing
and what are your favorites
i will see you guys in my next video
thank you so much for watching don't
forget to subscribe
like this video if you enjoyed it and uh
hit the bell
so you'll be notified when i post new
videos and that's it i'll see you guys
later
bye
[Music]